أبوكوما أونيوا أو
شبكة الفتيات زعيم أزياء نجمة ملصق 2 السيد
أنت تفعل
مع ستيك روز كاري عنب
نجوم Destory في Ginza Neighbours في القيام Phonemes
موضه
الصفحة الرئيسية 4 Stream s Kumano Car
أغلق وقل علنًا
أنا رئيس تاجر كيمونو في جينزا بطوكيو.
تم صنعه في منطقة أمامي أوشيما تلك.
يقال إن أوشيما تسوموجي هو أفضل كيمونو في فيلم النمر الواحد ، أليس كذلك؟
للوهلة الأولى ، إنه بريد إلكتروني بدون طيار
إنها مجموعة
يبدو أن مثل هذا الحزب الصغير الكسب سوف يتم حتى الآن أ
أعتقد أن هذه جماليات يابانية
[موسيقى]
إندر إندر ماري أبي ز أربعة ق في كل مكان
شخص ما للقيام 4 بار مخروط
أنا شخص يذهب إلى كاناي.
يوصف Oshima Tsumugi ، المصبوغ بالطين ، بأنه كيمونو بتاريخ لا يقل عن 1300 عام.
بقايا
يبدأ التأثير عندما تذهب إلى الجبل وتجمع الزعرور المزروع بشكل جميل بنفسك وتضعه في عمل بدوام كامل.
عندما يقوم هؤلاء الأشخاص الثلاثة بتوسيع مبيعاتهم بمحتوى الحديد في الحقل الموحل ، يكون شخص ما أسود
صبغ من 10 إلى 30 مرة واجعله يفسد في الوحل مرة أخرى.
الأسود الغامق هو أيضًا عدد المرات
أعتقد أن فوكامي لا يزال في اللون.
[موسيقى]
30 ذهب للقيام منطقة Astimare حيث يمكنك أن تأكل
يتم التعامل معه على أنه كيمونو لديك مع أفضل الجيل الثاني والثالث
كان الطين الذي بدا وكأنه يعود إلى المنزل صغيرًا ونظيفًا.
عندما تكون متحمسة ، إنها جميلة حقًا ، أليس كذلك؟
الآن أصبح أعظم سلاح للتعبير عن الذات.
أعتقد أن هذا ما هو عليه
خاصةً هذه المرة ، عندما أرتدي Oshima Tsumugi في أفضل عالم في اليابان ، أشعر بالفخر بذلك.
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]